last week a reporter posted a photo I
don't know if you saw this people get a
little crazy last week a reporter posted
a photo of President Trump that she
claimed the White House had altered to
make Trump's hands look bigger
here are the two versions of the photos
side by side now yeah what up know it ok
people some people thought maybe that's
true maybe the White House did that it
turns out she was wrong and that this
particular photo was not altered it was
not altered that's been cleared up but
that got us interested we took a look at
some other photos of Trump that the
White House recently released and it
does seem maybe some of them were
altered to make Trump's hands look just
a little bit bigger for example here's
Trump making a speech last week it
seemed to me here he is addressing the
press the very next day there's a Trump
with him were saying the Pledge of
Allegiance now this one probably there's
this one with his meeting the prime
minister Theresa May of Britain
that's just stupid
anybody can all agree that awesome
stupid we're on the same page
you